[Música]
mónica calizaya conduce un programa de
televisión esa actriz de teatro y
representa a bandas de música pero la
pandemia mermó esas actividades y ella
se convirtió en una pionera de la
confección de ropa de bioseguridad para
cholitas aymaras
que es igual que el de 2 es así es
cerrado
y pues la diferencia esta es un corte en
a
que puede diferenciar y además estar a
la moda de la cholita paceña con la
competencia el negocio decayó y mónica
también tuvo que dedicarse a la
repostería aunque trabaja desde la
madrugada sus ingresos siempre están al
límite en mi caso le digo es complicado
porque no se está generando lo que se
tendría que generar y pues el tiempo
pasa uno trata de rellenar algunos
huecos como quien dice no para poder
pagar banco para poder pagar muchos
cosas como muchas bolivianas mónica
tiene varios trabajos y enfrenta sola la
crianza de sus dos hijos la
investigadora silvia escobar señala que
la pandemia en bolivia ha provocado un
fuerte retroceso en la situación laboral
de la mujer pese a los enormes esfuerzos
que ellas hacen cada día la pandemia lo
que más ha afectado después al mundo
laboral
y el tema en el caso de las mujeres es
tan crítico como que tienen menos empleo
tienen más precariedad del trabajo
quienes han quedado ocupadas y tienen
mucho más trabajo en el ámbito no
remunerado del hogar en bolivia una de
cada tres mujeres tiene trabajo
asalariado y un 50% son trabajadoras por
cuenta propia una realidad dura cuando
la mujer es la única que garantiza los
ingresos del hogar